Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank,"
we celebrate America's heroes.
I've been a firefighter
for 13 years.
Two years as
a Peace Corps volunteer.
I'm a maternity nurse.
A couple deployments
to Iraq.
You are one impressive dude.
‐How much have you sold?
‐20,000 total.
Wow.
‐Um, I sold my home, so I...
‐Whoa. You're all‐in.
You're just like the banks
that won't give me a loan.
I'm not a bank.
I'm an investor.
I'm a big believer
in social enterprise.
Social enterprise
is the future of business.
‐I love this story.
‐I'll buy the entire company.
Whoa.
I believe
in the American dream.
This was on the back
of a fireman.
I do feel that this was what
I was put on this Earth to do.
What I think really
sets us apart is the story.
You're an American hero.
In this day and age,
authentic is hard to buy.
Whoo!
♪♪
Narrator: First into the tank
is a product borne
from the entrepreneur's
experience as a pediatric nurse.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Melissa Gersin,
and I'm from Boston.
I'm here seeking $100,000
for a 10% stake
in my company Tranquilo.
Have you ever wondered
why the first thing
a baby does
when they're born is to cry?
It's because they've just lost
the safety and security
of the womb ‐‐
the only thing
they've ever known.
I'm a maternity nurse
and an infant‐crying specialist.
I know the secret to stop
any fussy baby's wails.
The trick is to activate
a baby's calming response
by mimicking what
they've experienced in the womb.
But constantly rocking your baby
in your arms is exhausting,
so I developed
the Tranquilo mat,
the best possible way to
calm any crying baby in seconds.
And, most importantly,
it really works.
[ Baby crying ]
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Mm.
[ Crying stops ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Crying ]
‐Ohh.
‐Aw!
[ Coos ]
John: [ Laughs ]
Cuban: Yeah.
That's great.
‐You have one big enough for me?
‐Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
And when you're done,
Tranquilo mat fits nicely
into any diaper bag.
With a waterproof interior
and a washable cover,
it can withstand any mess.
We're ready to save the sanity
of parents around the globe.
So, Sharks, are you ready
to invest
in this incredible product?
Can we see it?
John: Yeah.
Yes, of course.
♪♪
So the one in the packaging
is for Lori
'cause I know
she loves packaging.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐There you go, Lori.
‐Thank you.
‐Stop crying.
[ Chuckles ]
It's heavy.
The packaging is heavy, yes,
but not the actual mat.
‐Thank you.
‐I'm ready to take a nap.
How do we turn it on,
Melissa?
Yep, so in order to turn it on,
you're gonna want
to press and hold
the universal power button.
‐It's a vibrating blanket.
‐It's a vibrating mat, yes.
Right.
So the other button
has multiple modes.
‐Oh, faster. Faster.
‐So there's a medium
and then a high
and then the fourth one
is a heartbeat setting.
‐Ah!
‐So if you guys close your eyes
and kind of hold it like this
and take a deep breath in,
you'll feel those nice, soothing
heartbeat‐type vibrations.
So, Melissa,
I have a newborn at home.
When they cry, they say
it's a couple reasons ‐‐
gas, hungry, this and that.
But then the doctors say
after a while,
let them cry it out.
Don't answer them all the time.
‐Can't do it.
Does this create a bad habit?
Oftentimes, when parents come in
and say, "My baby's crying,"
the doctor doesn't know what
to do, so they say, "It's gas.
It's acid reflux."
They just kind of ‐‐ They're
at a loss for what to say.
‐Yeah, I see. Yeah.
‐Yeah.
‐There's a patent on this?
‐I do have a patent, yes, sir.
So it's a utility patent,
and it's based on the ‐‐
the way that the motors
are arrayed
so that you can feel
the vibrations
throughout the entire pad.
Good for you.
‐Well, have you sold any?
‐Yeah.
So, we've done, um,
$65,000 in sales
in the last 7 1/2 months
through our website
as well as on Amazon.
And we've had a few boutiques
reach out to us.
That's pretty good.
What price
are you selling them at?
We currently retail this mat
for $85,
but since we've done
market testing,
we know that we can actually
sell it for about $99.
And what does it cost you
to make it?
We've narrowed it down
to about $20.
Well, I‐I‐I'm curious
on why you think
the company is worth
$1 million.
Well, you know, as I mentioned,
we have a patent.
We have quite a bit of sales
in just seven months time.
We plan to roll out to all moms
because moms talk to other moms.
So that's kind of our next push
within this space
and then ultimately going
to be baby‐shower gift.
Can you get your price point
down, do you think?
Yes, we could, but we are trying
to go as a premium product.
One of the big things
that I stand for is safety.
Being a nurse, you know,
I take my oath to do no harm
seriously.
I don't want to get to the point
where I'm making
a product cheaply
that is not safe.
How did you come up
with this idea?
When I came up with this idea,
I was actually in the hospital,
and I had three fussy babies
that were all undergoing
medical treatment,
and I couldn't pick them up
to hold them.
So my colleague said,
"You really need to offer this
to the hospital
because you work here.
You know, you need to offer it."
It's like their proprietary
information.
So I offered it to them,
and one of the things
they came back
and said quite quickly
afterwards was,
"Nah, we're not interested
in pursuing this with you,"
what have you.
‐Why?
‐And ‐‐
It was some guy in an office
who really didn't see the value.
However,
once we became produced,
the nurses
that I used to work with
were some of
our first customers.
How much are you making,
Melissa, as a nurse right now?
Like $1,000 a month, maybe.
‐How much?
‐$1,000.
Wow.
You got to be full‐time on this
if it's gonna fly.
I am.
I'm working 80 hours a week
with 8 hours a week
as a nurse occasionally.
Yeah, but the thing is
if you really want
to make this a business,
you got to stop working.
How much of your own money
do you have in this?
Yeah, so I'm $198,000
into this process.
‐Wow!
Wow.
Where'd you get that money?
So I actually had
a bit of an inheritance.
‐You spent your inheritance?
‐Uh, I did.
Yeah.
Good for you.
Um, I'm pretty sure
my grandfather
would be very proud of me.
Good for you.
Um, and also, um,
I sold my home.
‐Whoa! You're all‐in.
‐So I d‐‐
I‐I am all‐in to this.
You know what,
I've got an offer.
♪♪
But it'll be contingent
on licensing play.
I will offer you $100,000
for, um, 20%
contingent on if I can go out
and license it.
Melissa, if you really want
to make this a business,
you got to be
100% focused.
I'll give you $250,000
for 25%.
You've got to stop working.
You've got to be 100%.
Kevin's getting smart.
That's enough capital
to get you going.
Replace your salary,
and you can build
some inventory
'cause I actually think
it's an eloquent solution
to a perpetual problem.
So you're giving her
the same value she's asking for.
Yeah, yeah,
but she needs more money.
It's a good offer, Melissa.
It's exactly what you were
looking for in terms of value.
Greiner:
It's an amazing offer, frankly.
Kevin knows he's got
all the Honeymoon,
the Honeyfund, and all that.
No, this means
there must be something.
And once they get pregnant,
he can sell it to them.
O'Leary:
Mark is right.
I have a massive database
of people that are
gonna buy this,
and you know what,
I love love.
I love babies.
I can't stand crying babies.
Anybody else?
Any other offers?
Honestly, I think he gave you
a great offer.
He's giving you basically
what you asked for,
but he's giving you more money.
But you have to give up
a lot more equity.
Which is smart in this case.
Greiner: So the questions is
does that sound appealing
to you?
Because, you know,
sometimes you come into the Tank
and an offer comes,
and then you blink,
and an offer goes.
And we don't want you to blink.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
Daymond has offered
pediatric nurse Melissa
$100,000 for 20%,
contingent on a licensing deal,
and Kevin has offered
$250,000 for 25%,
contingent on her leaving
her job as a nurse
to work full‐time
on her vibrating baby mat
company Tranquilo.
You know, sometimes
you come into the Tank
and an offer comes, and then
you blink, and an offer goes.
And we don't want you to blink.
I think we're all waiting
to see what you do.
So 25% seems a bit high
considering the fact
that I've sold my home,
that I've blown through,
you know, my inheritance,
and I'm still working.
It's exactly
the same valuation.
I just asked you
if you needed more money.
Cuban: You're getting
cash for it.
Melissa, you got to remember
one important thing ‐‐
Make sure that this is what's
in the best interest
for you and the company.
I mean, if ‐‐ if I could get
an offer that has, you know,
$200,000 for 15% equity,
I would take that in a second.
No, you've raised the value,
Melissa.
That doesn't make sense
to me.
You're saying now you want
a higher valuation
to take more cash.
I just don't want to lose
that much equity.
I mean, I've put blood, sweat ‐‐
Well, if you want to do
$200,000, I'll do 20%.
I'm giving you the same value
and how much money you need.
We understand the hesitancy
to work with Kevin.
It's natural.
[ Chuckles ]
It's an instinct
everybody has.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
O'Leary:
Actually, I‐I'm probably your
best Shark because of all ‐‐
Hold on, let me turn
my Tranquilo mat on
so I can calm down before ‐‐
I'm your best Shark
because I have so many
online businesses
with families and young ‐‐
young mothers.
This does fit his wheelhouse.
It really does.
It's huge.
So, Melissa,
let's just do the math, right?
Melissa,
do you want to quit your job?
It's not even about
quitting your job, right?
No, wait.
‐She answered that, Lori.
‐Well, let's not ‐‐ Let's ‐‐
Mark, instead of you
answering for her,
let her speak for herself.
I actually ‐‐ I mean,
I do feel that this was what
I was put on this Earth to do
was to develop this product.
So why would you want
to do anything else?
You're right, I ‐‐
My entrepreneurs work
all day and night.
They want to.
That's why they're growing
a business.
I do want to.
John: Kevin, I have a feeling
that she just doesn't want
to do the deal with you.
‐No, that's ‐‐
‐Well, you should say that.
That ‐‐ No, that's not the case.
I'm just ‐‐ I'm ‐‐
I'm just curious with
the other Sharks, you know,
if there's any ‐‐
Herjavec: So, Melissa,
Kevin's offer
is $200,000 for 20%.
Mm‐hmm.
You're saying if you got
$200,000 for 15% ‐‐
I would take that in a second
and ‐‐ and walk right now.
But you came in asking
for $100,000 for 10%, correct?
It's that equity peace again.
[ Chuckles ]
So...
O'Leary:
Would you quit your job or not?
'Cause I actually
won't do the deal unless
you quit your job.
Yeah, of course.
I would quit my job.
♪♪
And I'll simplify it.
I'm out.
Okay.
O'Leary: Okay.
So Daymond's offering you
the $100,000 for 20%
with a contingency
that he can license it.
But the bigger issue now
is that I see
that she's, um, not really
a decisive person.
I'm out.
♪♪
I'm willing to do $200,000
for 20%,
which is double
what you asked for
with no change in your
valuation.
But I'll be clear ‐‐
I'm not gonna do
the $200,000 for 15%.
‐Okay.
‐So if we can't agree on this,
then it's not gonna work.
‐And, Lori, are you out?
‐Lori, do you have an offer?
♪♪
Robert,
what are you doing?
Herjavec:
Well, Melissa, first of all,
I want to thank you
for being a nurse.
I think it's one of those jobs
that people work
incredibly hard for
and never get
the recognition.
You're an American hero,
and I very much appreciate it.
Thank you.
Um, I think
it's a great product.
And better
than the product,
I think you're a great
businesswoman.
We've thrown
a lot of stuff at you,
and I think you're gonna
make this work.
♪♪
You said you'd do $200,000
for 15%,
and you'll take that deal
in a second.
In a second.
That's my offer.
‐Done.
‐All right.
[ Laughter ]
‐Thank you.
‐That's awesome! Thank you!
Great job!
[ Laughs ]
Thank you!
Thank you very much!
‐Congratulations.
‐Sorry, Kevin.
‐Congratulations, Melissa.
‐Hopefully you can, uh ‐‐
You can use this
to calm yourself.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah!
She didn't like you!
I love her even more!
[ Chuckles ]
To get a deal today ‐‐
It really validates
what I've done.
[ Voice breaking ]
And it means that that ‐‐
that hundred ‐‐ that money
wasn't for nothing ‐‐
that I ‐‐ that I have
a great idea,
that I have a great product,
and that we can ‐‐
we can do this.
Narrator: In season seven,
military wives Lisa Bradley
and Cameron Cruse
made a deal with Mark Cuban
for their bag company
R. Riveter,
which gives jobs
to fellow military spouses.
You are a social network
through action.
I mean, you could be
the future of ‐‐
of manufacturing,
in some respects,
Narrator:
Let's see how they're doing now.
Lisa:
The year before "Shark Tank,"
we did $300,000 in sales.
It's been five months
since we aired,
and we've already done
$1.1 million in sales.
Cameron: The increase in sales
was really exciting,
but it was also kind of scary
because we knew
that at that point,
we were gonna have to start
fulfilling those orders.
As military spouses,
we have our own battles.
We may not be the ones
that have the uniform,
but we are doing
everything that we can
to support
our service member
so that they can do
the things that they need to do
to protect our country.
$1.1 million.
That's what it's all about.
Working with Mark
is a company's dream scenario.
You have this amazing
business mind
that you can really call upon
every week if you need to.
Expanding with Westfield
has been great.
One of the most exciting things
coming up for R. Riveter
is our partnership
with Westfield Mall.
We're opening up
our first retail store
in Bethesda, Maryland.
Part of your next
weekly report ‐‐
put together what you feel
your biggest challenges
are gonna be at the store.
Obviously, we'll be able
to help you out with that.
All right, perfect.
We'll get that to you next week.
Appreciate it, guys.
See you later.
Lisa: R. Riveter really created
a new way of manufacturing.
It's not just about going
to the store and buying a bag
because it has
a certain name on it.
Our customers are buying
our bags
because it's helping
military spouses.
It's the process
of being an American
and being proud
of who we are.
Green light.
Go.
Cameron:
What I get to do is show
my kids and my husband
that we've grown something
that's now helping
dozens and dozens of military
spouses across the country,
and my kids can really see
the full picture
of the American dream.
♪♪
My name's Renee Wallace.
And I'm
her business partner, Dale.
And we live
in Portsmouth, Ohio.
I was a military
intelligence officer,
and I was fortunate enough
to be assigned
to the 10th
Special Forces Group.
I was in active duty
from 2003 to 2007,
and I served
two deployments to Iraq.
♪♪
I love Portsmouth.
Born and raised here.
The only time
I've ever been gone
was with college
and in the military.
However, when I returned,
it just didn't seem
like it was the same town.
Just been ravaged
with drug abuse
and just kind of seemed like
the life blood
had been sapped from it.
The lessons I learned
from the military
I brought
back to Portsmouth
and decided
to open up a gym.
Big kick! Pop!
Dale:
We decided to start a business
to provide jobs
and heal our local economy.
Dale and I met
when I became a member
at the gym five years ago.
I've always had a passion
for making natural products,
and after I met Dale,
we came together
to create something
that we could sell
to the members of the gym.
There's no doubt in my mind
Portsmouth's coming back.
We're coming on "Shark Tank"
'cause we want to show people
the American dream is alive
in a small town.
Whoo!
♪♪
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐My name is Dale King.
I like short shorts.
I love freedom.
And I believe
in the American dream.
My name is Renee Wallace,
and although Dale believes
he's the beauty,
I'm definitely the brains
of our company, Doc Spartan.
We are seeking $75,000
for 15% of our business.
Sharks,
life is a contact sport,
and war wounds
are a part of the game.
Think of all the times
you or a loved one
have encountered nicks,
cuts, scrapes, wounds,
rashes, burns,
and even scars.
Daymond, as a gym owner,
think of all the times
your members are ripping their
hands or busting their shins
during the course
of their intense workouts.
Lori, think of all the nasty
curling‐iron burns
you suffered
while prepping to go on to QVC.
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughing ] I have.
Dale:
Even you, Mr. Wonderful.
Think of all the countless
paper cuts you've had to endure
while counting
your $100 bills.
That all changes now
with Doc Spartan's
combat‐ready ointment,
a completely all‐natural,
fast‐healing first‐aid ointment
trusted by members of
the special operations community
all the way
to neighborhood moms.
Now, Sharks,
the only issue remains ‐‐
Who's ready to join us
on our mission to heal
America's wounds?
We'd love to give you
some samples.
O'Leary: Yeah.
Yeah,
why are your shorts so short?
‐Yeah. [ Chuckles ]
‐What's that sticking out?
That would be freedom
sticking out, Mark, but...
[ Laughter ]
Unfortunately, Barbara ‐‐
Barbara's not here,
but I'm heeding her advice
when she said
if you want to get attention,
wear a short skirt
with bright colors.
So this is all I had
at the moment.
Herjavec: So, Dale,
what does the product do?
How do I use it?
What's it for?
So it's more of a,
"What doesn't it do?"
It's a completely all‐natural
first‐aid ointment.
Everything
that is inside that product
came from our community.
‐And what's your community?
‐I come from Portsmouth, Ohio.
I went away to serve some time
in the military.
I was an Army
intelligence officer.
I served a couple deployments
to Iraq, uh, did my time,
and was fortunate enough
to come back to my hometown.
And our area had become
the most depressed
and most economically depressed
and unhealthiest area
in the state.
I wanted to try to do something
to make that better,
so what I did is
I‐I created a gym.
[ Chuckles ]
I found
an abandoned warehouse
and charged
5 bucks a workout.
That's how Renee and I met
was through that
abandoned warehouse at the time.
‐You guys are business partners.
‐Yes, absolutely. Yeah.
So, how does
Doc Spartan's come to fruition?
Well, um,
I'm a mom of three,
and I'm married
to a former Kiowa pilot
who served 10 years
in the Army.
I had a little girl,
and I started researching
the benefits of essential oils
because I didn't want
to use chemicals
on myself and my daughter.
And so I started making
my own skin‐care products.
So Dale then approached me
and asked me
if I could work on creating
a healing ointment
for when we rip our hands.
It's 'cause you're not using
the Natural Grip.
You were trying to heal hands.
[ Laughter ]
Well, we do sell those
in our gym, Robert.
Tell me the applications,
where I would use this.
Any type of skin‐related
ailment, it's gonna work.
‐How about a cut?
‐Cuts?
Do I put it on
before a Band‐Aid?
Absolutely.
It accelerates healing.
We'd love to show you
some before‐and‐afters.
Oh. Okay.
‐Whoa!
‐So, yeah.
‐So this is scar healing.
Nothing else was on that?
You didn't use any type of ‐‐
Nothing else was on it.
This was
a 50‐year‐old mother
who had to get
a knee‐replacement surgery.
This is about six
or seven months afterwards.
Tell me what's in it.
It's coconut oil, beeswax,
Vitamin E, sweet almond oil,
and then essential oils
lavender, eucalyptus,
and tea tree.
And you ‐‐ you put
all that mixture together
just by trial and error?
Yeah, yeah.
Just based ‐‐
Well, they're also
known medicinals.
Yeah.
Tell me
where in the drugstore
is the ideal position
for this product?
Dale: So we're not in any
big‐chain retailers yet,
but if you were to go,
it would be
in the ‐‐
in the first‐aid aisle.
Herjavec: So, Dale, you're not
selling retail today, you said.
You're only selling online,
I take it.
We're ‐‐ We're ‐‐
75% of our sales
comes from
our e‐commerce website.
However, we are
in other independent gyms.
We're in tattoo shops.
We haven't even talked about
the tattoo‐shop application yet.
What are your sales today?
We've been in business
11 months ‐‐ $56,000.
What does it sell for?
What does it cost you to make?
That costs 95 cents to make,
and we sell it for $9.99.
And then the big tin costs us
$1.70 to make,
and we sell it for $14.99.
Guys,
here's why I've been quiet.
If you watch the show, you know
I get a little bit freaked out
when people make
a lot of claims.
‐Absolutely.
‐When you say,
"I've got a cure
for that," right?
"This happened.
We're a cure."
It works when you're small
because no one's
paying attention to you yet.
Mm‐hmm.
But in order to scale,
you have to be really careful
about your claims.
With your investment,
we're gonna be able
to go get those tests.
♪♪
Greiner: I'm gonna just
tell you my thoughts here.
It's not super‐clear.
It says "combat‐ready ointment."
So combat‐ready ‐‐
That doesn't mean
combat‐healing.
‐Right.
‐Sure.
You know? So ‐‐
So it needs to say,
"first‐aid ointment."
Yes. To just see it
in the store really fast,
it's kind of scary‐looking.
‐Sure.
‐Like, you look at this ‐‐
‐I like it.
‐With a partner like you,
that's why we're here ‐‐
for ‐‐ for this advice
and suggestions and to ‐‐
You need to have already
figured this out, right?
This needed to be part
of your research.
of your preparation.
I don't think you've done
the preparatory work
that you need to,
so for those reasons, I'm out.
Lori is the person here
who really is the expert
in regards to testing
and claims.
I don't know about
any of this testing,
so I would be the blind
leading the blind.
So I have to be out.
Greiner:
I thank you for your service,
and I think that you've done
a good job in formulating.
‐Thank you.
‐To me,
you have a long road ahead
because you have
a lot of competition.
But you have
a good quality product.
‐Thank you, Lori.
‐I'm out.
♪♪
I like the product.
I like the eucalyptus smell.
But, uh, for me, I don't think
this is investable yet.
I'm out.
‐Thank you.
♪♪
Herjavec:
I completely disagree
with the other Sharks.
I like the branding.
You can sell it
at tattoo parlors,
places where ointment is.
In gyms.
I mean, that's ‐‐
I actually see
maybe a new category,
and I like things
that are new in a category.
That's what we did
with Natural Grip.
You know, she created
a brand‐new category
to stop your hands
from blistering.
This is maybe if you don't
use that product...
Right.
... you get this.
So I'll go along for the ride.
$75,000 for 25%.
Can you meet us at 20%?
‐No.
‐[ Laughs ]
Come on, man.
It's worth it at 25%.
Good for you.
Good for you, Dale.
Stick to your guns, Dale.
It's ‐‐ It's worth it on that.
Stick to your guns.
First beer's on you?
Yeah.
Ohh, let's do it!
[ Laughs ]
Let's do it!
Deal.
All right.
Let's do it!
‐Come here, man.
‐Congratulations, guys.
Ohh! Holy crap!
You don't know
how much this means, man.
‐You don't know. This is ‐‐
‐Good luck, guys.
Oh, my God, we did it.
I got to get a pair
of those shorts.
[ Exhales sharply ]
Yes!
Whoo!
We're just two podunks
from Ohio.
Uh, it's incredible.
It's such a feeling of relief.
What Robert saw in us
was a belief.
He saw two people willing
to make it happen
and willing to work
their asses off to get it done.
♪♪
[ Exhales ]
Man: Camera set.
All Sharks, please stand by.
5, 4, 3, 2...
All go.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a healthy snack
inspired by the entrepreneur's
experience
as a Peace Corps volunteer.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
My name is Evan Delahanty
coming to you from Akron, Ohio.
I'm the founder
of Peaceful Fruits,
and I'm here to ask
for 75,000 of your dollars
in return for 20% of my company.
That's because I know
that together,
we can make
fruit snacks great again.
So what makes
our fruit snacks so great?
Well, first, they're actually
made from fruit.
And not just any fruit,
we use the most popular
super fruit in the world ‐‐
acai.
It's our main ingredient.
We take
those beautiful whole fruits.
We run them through
our all‐natural,
trade‐secret production process.
What you get is food
that you can feel good about.
And that's the other thing
that really sets us apart.
I started Peaceful Fruits
after two years
in the Amazon Rainforest
as a Peace Corps volunteer.
We partner with the local people
to harvest the acai
and empower them
to protect their rainforest,
to protect their way of life
from the threat of extinction.
And now people are responding
to our snacks and to that story
'cause you've seen it happen
with organic produce ‐‐
fair‐trade coffee,
now ethical chocolate.
I'm ready to do
the same thing for fruit snacks.
Who's ready to take a bite?
‐Let's go.
‐Let's try it.
‐Yeah, let's try it.
‐Bring on the "osutite."
‐What is "osutite"?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐There you go, sir.
Which one is the acai‐a?
So acai is how you pronounce it,
just to be...
‐Exactly, Robert.
‐Ah‐sigh‐ee.
And both of these ‐‐
We have two flavors ‐‐
the acai pineapple
and the acai apple.
Both of which are there
for you guys to enjoy.
‐Where do you manufacture this?
‐This is good.
I prefer "best ever,"
but I'll take "good," you know?
[ Chuckles ]
So the way
that we produce it ‐‐
We work with folks
with disabilities
in an industrial kitchen
there in Akron.
They're able to follow
exactly what I need
because
they're so carefully managed.
Our process
is totally all‐natural.
So we don't need
any of the weird mad science.
We don't need
any of the additives.
It's literally just the fruit.
You're not the only one
doing fruit
or snacks based off of acai.
There's a lot of people.
There are,
but we're the only one
that actually uses it
as the main ingredient.
The acai is a very healthy
thing to eat.
It is.
It's known as a super food
because it's one of the best
sources of antioxidants,
which have been linked to cancer
prevention and anti‐aging.
Let me just clear
the field.
I have an investment
in a fruit‐snack company.
I was listening to see
if there's a synergy somehow.
Mm‐hmm.
I see it as
a competitive product.
I'm already in that space.
I'm out.
You said that you were
in the Peace Corps.
Can you share with us
that background, that story?
I‐I'd love
to tell you about that.
So ‐‐ Actually,
we have some photos, so...
I was there in Suriname,
which is a little country
just northeast of Brazil,
and these people are subsisting
on less than a few dollars
a day.
And that's what makes
this product
really great
from a social perspective.
I mean,
working with those people,
what you really see
is why social enterprise
is the future of business.
The only way to do sustainable
community development
is help everyone involved
make money.
‐They speak English there?
‐They speak Saramaccan.
26,000 people in the world
and this guy
speak that language,
so great résumé skill.
Tell us something
in Saramaccan.
[ Speaks Saramaccan ]
Ha!
‐Wow!
‐Thank you.
I just ‐‐ I just said, uh,
"What do you want me to say?
I think you should buy
some acai."
‐Wow.
Evan, you are
one impressive dude.
I got to tell you.
Well,
I appreciate you saying it.
Yeah. Wow, that's ‐‐
But you already said you're out.
[ Laughter ]
I did.
It hurts.
‐Let's talk about the numbers.
‐Uh, what are your costs?
So I sell it wholesale
for 85 cents,
and then it retails
for $1.25 to $1.50,
which is very much in range
with our competitors.
‐How much have you sold?
‐About $20,000 total.
‐Dollars, not units.
‐Yes, yes.
‐Okay.
‐Do you have a retailer
that said they'll take this on
and give you shelf space?
Yeah, actually.
So we just got approved
by Whole Foods,
and we're gonna be
launching with them shortly.
‐In the Ohio region?
‐Just in the Ohio area.
They're gonna give us actually
a couple different locations
in the store.
‐Yeah.
‐We're also about to launch
with Giant Eagle
Market District.
It's got to sell itself,
right?
Uh, it ‐‐ it does
for the most part,
but obviously, starting out,
we are 100% committed to demos.
I'm gonna live
in that Whole Foods store.
We're hustling to get this done.
I mean, you know,
it's hard to get the name out.
And you look at every year,
you know,
America finds a new super food,
which ‐‐ they all exist, right?
So whether it's kombucha
or now kale salad or ‐‐
I think acai's had some staying
power, fortunately, yeah.
‐Or pomegranate. Right?
‐Sure enough.
I think it's just
a big challenge,
uh, which you have dedicated
yourself to taking on,
but I just don't have any
interest in this, so I'm out.
Fair enough.
I appreciate your ‐‐ your input.
I'm a big believer in
social enterprise, all right?
I appreciate that.
I think it's the future
of capitalism.
I agree.
Capitalism's evolving,
and there's a lot of people
who are confused
and getting left behind.
Absolutely.
But still, the product
has to be compelling.
Mm‐hmm. What I think really sets
us apart is the story, right?
You have the acai.
You have the super food,
which is a big differentiator.
But the social enterprise
should come with the product
that you want to buy...
I agree.
...as opposed to be the reason
why you buy the product.
Absolutely.
It's the extra hook.
Right?
Right. That's the challenge
you have here.
I don't know that
it's going to be an easy sale.
You're going to have to go
through that branding process,
and the risk‐reward
just isn't there for me.
‐I hear you on that.
‐So for those reasons, I'm out.
I‐I hear you on that,
and I think this is the future
of business, right?
We have to figure out
how to make money.
That's the number‐one goal
of business, but ‐‐
‐So true, Evan.
‐But ‐‐ But if we don't
figure out how to take care
of our communities
at the same time,
we're gonna lose
places to spend that money.
Not just that, but
it's communicating that story.
Evan, I love the story, but
we're back in America now, okay?
We are.
You know, your deal ‐‐
$75,000 for 20% is not crazy,
but it's not enough money
to roll this puppy out.
Well, I'm happy to think bigger
if you want to ‐‐
want to make an offer.
I say respectfully not for me.
I'm out.
Well,
I appreciate you saying that.
Thank you very much.
Evan, you are
a great entrepreneur.
Thank you for saying so.
The only problem here is
your competition in the arena
is huge.
There's a million
fruit snacks out there ‐‐
strips, rolls, bites.
I think you're fantastic
and super‐smart,
and you're gonna make it.
For me, the investment ‐‐
the fruit snack ‐‐
isn't the right one.
I'm out...
but I have no doubt
that you're going to make
quite something
of yourself.
Well, I appreciate the thoughts
from all of you guys.
‐Evan, thank you very much.
‐I really ‐‐
‐Good luck, Evan.
‐Thank you, Evan.
‐Good luck.
‐Thank you.
We didn't get that deal,
but I'm still working really
hard to make this a success.
I'm building Peaceful Fruits
to make a difference
for the people in Akron,
the people in the Amazon.
So it's disappointing to not get
that immediate bump up today,
but I know
we're gonna get there.
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a product made from gear
that protects firefighters
on the front line.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Niki Rasor.
I'm Matt Rasor.
My company is called
Fire Fighter Turn‐Out Bags,
and I'm here seeking
a $250,000 investment
for 33% of my company.
Sharks, I've been a firefighter
for 13 years,
and on every shift I work,
I wear this turnout gear.
Firefighters wear this gear
to protect ourselves
from the dangerous elements
we face in doing our job.
Typically, every firefighter
is issued two sets,
and we use those two sets
for 10 years.
We then turn in those two sets
and get two new sets.
And this creates a unique
problem for fire departments ‐‐
what to do
with all this old gear.
One day Matt came home
with his turnout coat,
and he asked me
to remove that pocket.
So I plucked it off,
and I made a cool,
little bag out of it ‐‐
this one.
[ Chuckles ]
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Once I took it out,
I'd get stopped
wherever I went
by people asking me
where they could get one.
And that's how Fire Fighter
Turn‐Out Bags was born.
Now we have every type of bag
you can imagine.
So, Sharks,
who wants to be
the hero of Fire Fighter
Turn‐Out Bags
and make
a smoking‐hot offer?!
[ Laughter ]
‐Good job.
‐Can we see samples?
Good job!
I'm on "Shark Tank"!
Cuban: Oh, Lord.
We do that every day.
Sorry.
I can't contain myself.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
All right.
Which one is for Lori?
Woman: You can take
any bag you would like.
Here, Kevin.
Black for you.
Niki, how long did it take you
to get on "Shark Tank"?
It took me years.
But you know what, it taught me
that I am in this on my own...
It's very cool.
...and not to rely
on anything or anyone.
Wow.
Never take the first note.
How do you scale it?
You know, one of the things
about getting on "Shark Tank" ‐‐
If you do a great pitch
and people like it,
you're gonna get
10,000 orders.
So how many suits
are you getting
out of the fireman system?
Fire departments don't want
to throw this stuff away.
Well, if they don't want
to throw it away,
what do they want
to do with it?
What do they do with it?
Currently,
it just goes in the landfill.
‐Really?
‐Or they store it. Yes.
I get calls every day
by a fire department
wanting me to take
their old gear.
What does it cost
to make one of these bags,
and what do you sell it at?
And where do you make it,
and how do you make it?
My business is operated
in my basement.
We were in a factory.
I tried to kind of compact it
and make it work for my life,
and it was not doing that.
It was expanding and expanding.
‐You mean you went to a factory,
and it was too much?
‐You went in a factory?
‐It was overwhelming.
‐I was ‐‐ I got a warehouse,
and it was taking over
my life.
So I said, "This is too much.
I'm gonna scale down."
And it did not
scale down with me.
It did its own thing,
and it got bigger.
And so now I need
to get back into a warehouse.
But why do you want to go
back to the warehouse?
I didn't know what
I didn't know back then.
I didn't know how to set up
a manufacturing facility.
I didn't understand
the electrical I needed.
I didn't know
how to manage people.
There was a lot
of mistakes I made,
and they were all
very expensive.
What does it cost you,
and what do you sell them for?
‐Okay.
‐Okay, so...
‐Hold on.
‐Go ahead.
And, Niki, at some point,
you can tell us
how much you sold
last year.
We make ‐‐
We grossed $194,000.
‐Good for you.
‐Yeah.
‐So you sold...
‐And we profited ‐‐
We profited $70,000.
How much money
have you guys invested?
We haven't invested
any of our own personal money.
Oh, good,
so you just started making it.
It's all sweat equity.
‐She just started making it.
It's paying
for itself and ‐‐
‐How are you raising capital?
‐How much are you spending?
Wait.
What does a bag cost?
I'm dying to know.
Yeah,
how much does this bag ‐‐
The average bag is $130.
That's your cost?
That bag costs me
about $60 to make.
Whoa!
Well, how much
is a duffel bag?
$350.
‐Whoa.
‐Wow.
I smell a requirement
for capital.
What have you borrowed?
There is a huge requirement,
and I have taken out
a couple of loans.
O'Leary: How much?
I have $40,000
in, um, high‐interest loans.
How high interest?
Here's a ‐‐
Here's the highest‐interest
loan that I have.
Okay.
I borrowed $20,000.
Uh, if I take seven months
to pay it back,
it's gonna cost me $30,000.
That's 50% interest.
I don't regret doing that.
I needed that money.
You're a wonderful lady
with lots of energy,
but you need a manager.
Somebody in here
has to take over and say,
"I do care about the logistics.
I do care about the cost
of rent," all right?
The truth is I don't think
of you as a great manager.
Oh, you don't?
I think of you
as a great inventor.
I am a slam‐dunk manager.
I don't think so, Niki.
Every employee that I have
loves their job.
I don't think
I'm a bad manager.
I look at you ‐‐
I've heard your story.
It's very compelling.
But it's very hard
for me to understand
how to deploy $250,000
and ever have a hope
of getting it back.
Something's not adding up for me
numbers‐wise.
If you made $70,000
in free cash flow last year,
why did you have to take
a $40,000 loan now?
Well ‐‐
Can I answer one thing?
Yes.
We ‐‐
Just in the last month,
We've kind of, like,
doubled our ‐‐
our ‐‐ our payroll.
Work force.
So because you double ‐‐
You're taking money
not to buy inventory,
not to buy cost of goods,
but to expand the business.
You're trying to gear up.
So you're thinking ‐‐
‐We're trying to gear up.
‐I'm gearing up.
Okay, we got that.
But I can make these bags
a lot cheaper.
How?
These come from something
that's already constructed.
That's why it's taking
so long.
But I'm going to have
another service
where I get these bags
and I stamp the pattern out.
What?
All of the material
is on a roll.
I do it the way
normal people do it.
‐Okay, it's not ‐‐
‐No, no. That's authentic.
I don't think that's gonna work.
That's not gonna work.
‐Wait, what you're saying is...
‐Why isn't it gonna work?
It is working.
‐... you're gonna go ‐‐ Wait.
Let me see
if I understand this.
That's not an
authentic product, then.
‐No.
‐You're gonna go to mass‐produce
the look of these,
but take regular fabric,
and then ‐‐
‐Well, they're gonna be ‐‐
‐No, it's ‐‐ it's gonna be
the actual fabric that they use.
‐Just fireman fabric.
It's gonna be off a roll.
Now, listen ‐‐
You know, Niki, I think that's
a very dangerous place to go.
75% of the fire fighters ‐‐
‐No.
‐This bag fought fires.
O'Leary:
That's what you told me.
That's why I pay
300 bucks for it.
This was on the back
of a fireman.
John: Yeah.
‐You're changing your ‐‐
‐No, I'm not.
We're gonna offer ‐‐
We're gonna offer both.
Huge mistake.
One's gonna be a lot less
expensive to manufacture.
I'm knocking myself off.
That's what I'm gonna do.
So we'll pass that savings
on to the consumer.
No, no. The whole reason ‐‐
Do you know how compelled
people are to support you
because
you're supporting firemen?
Hang on. Hang on, Kevin.
Cuban:
It's a fine line, guys.
It's a fine line
to walk between ‐‐
It's not.
People are already doing it,
and they're selling.
I've seen it.
‐I know, but let me ‐‐
let me ‐‐ let me tell you
what I think about it.
First of all, this bag
is absolutely incredible.
‐Yeah, it's great.
‐From the way you sewed it,
I can see people
paying the money for it.
Thank you.
But I think
what we're sharing with you
is not that you're not
a good manager.
You could be a great manager,
but it's gonna take me to not
only give you an investment
but send a huge team in to ship,
bill, and everything ‐‐
to grow the business.
But at this stage,
it's hard for us to invest in.
And unfortunately,
I have to be out.
‐[ Scoffs ]
‐Look.
As Kevin said, it's not that
it looks like a fireman wore it.
It's the fact that a fireman
actually wore it.
Right.
The whole deal is
somebody wore this.
That's the whole deal.
‐That's not the whole deal.
You're missing it, Kevin.
‐No, it's not. No, look. I ‐‐
‐I've been to trade shows.
‐I think so.
Look, I can have my opinion.
We don't have to agree, okay?
I've been to trade shows,
and there's this guy.
He had a booth.
He's getting
all his stuff from China.
It's generic,
and there's no soul to it.
Well, then you should get
a manufacturer in China
to take that material
and knock that bag off.
Hold on.
Just let me get this across.
He's knocking me off!
Why can't I knock me off?!
Different business.
‐Different company.
‐It is not.
Look, no, they're wrong.
Niki. Niki.
‐I'm right. You're wrong, Cuban.
‐They are wrong!
‐You're wrong.
‐And I'm gonna explain to you ‐‐
Well, then,
you give her the money.
I'm gonna explain
to you why, right?
Lots of companies
have premium brands
that are authentic,
and then they have
less‐expensive versions
to reach a broader audience.
Where do you think she's gonna
get the capacity to do that?
That's a different issue.
She can't even build the ones
she's got orders for.
That ‐‐
That's a different issue, right?
[ Scoffs ]
That's not true.
Look, Niki, you should
be extremely proud of yourself.
You're ‐‐ You're hustling.
You're hitting it hard, right?
You're doing
a lot of great things.
But you're really a product,
not a company.
Okay.
That's the challenge.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Well, Niki,
I can't invest in this,
not because you're not terrific.
It's just not structured
to take $250,000 right now.
You're just like the banks
that won't give me a loan.
‐That's what ‐‐ No, it is.
‐It's not about loaning.
They only want
to loan you money...
Those guys
are taking advantage ‐‐
...unless you don't need it.
I'm not a bank.
I'm an investor.
So what I want to do
is build businesses, okay?
This is what
this money will do.
‐It will build this business.
‐No, it's ‐‐ it's not ‐‐
You're not ready
for my $250,000, Niki.
‐Okay. All right.
‐I'm sorry.
I have ‐‐
‐I respect your opinion.
♪♪
Niki,
$250,000 is a lot of money.
It is a lot of money.
I don't feel confident
I'd get it back.
I'm sorry.
I'm out.
[ Sighs ]
So what do you say?
I'm all‐in on
the fireman outfits
'cause that's authentic
to the brand.
In this day and age,
authentic is hard to buy.
I don't know
if you're the person that can
run and scale that business.
But I love the business.
I'll buy the entire company
for $500,000.
‐[ Exhales sharply ]
‐Ohh!
Lock, stock, and barrel.
I think my team can run it.
We'll work with you on some type
of a consulting agreement
with us.
But I think we can take that
company to another level.
[ Crying ]
That's my offer.
♪♪
Narrator: Three Sharks are out.
Niki and Matt
are seeking $250,000
for 33% of their company
Fire Fighter Turn‐Out Bags,
but Robert has offered
to buy out the entire company.
I'll buy the entire company
for $500,000.
Lock, stock, and barrel.
[ Crying ]
Ooh!
I'm just curious.
Why are you crying?
I just...
Overwhelmed?
Can I...?
It's okay.
Is it ‐‐
Is it the heels?
[ Laughter ]
Niki, I've never loved
a business so much on here...
Ohh!
...that I've wanted
to buy the whole thing.
I just love it.
I love everything about it.
‐You know what...?
What do you think?
I could never disappoint
the people
that I'm serving right now.
[ Exhales sharply ]
And all of you are right.
I...
Listen, I'm not sure
what you're going to say,
but I don't think
you've disappointed anybody.
Yeah, I...
I think you came up
with a fabulous idea.
Thank you.
I have a ton of admiration
for firemen, policemen,
people that risk their lives
every day to help all of us.
And not only
is it just something
that I feel passionately about,
but you have
a great sense of style.
Thank you.
Then there's the flip side
that happens
to so many entrepreneurs,
where people knock off
a great idea.
Right.
And they cut the prices,
and you're mad because
you're the designer.
Why shouldn't you be able
to make that, too?
Thank you.
I actually think
there's a market for both.
‐There is.
‐But the cool thing
that people would want
to really love and buy into
is that we could then donate
money to firemen's funds.
Right.
So that a certain percentage
of every bag sold
goes to firemen's charities.
Right.
I'd like to make you an offer.
Okay.
I would give you $250,000 for...
I'm gonna go 50‐50 partner,
and I'll tell you why ‐‐
because I'd like you
to be the designer,
but then I know me and my team
would need to take over
the manufacturing,
the charity donation, the books.
[ Sighs ]
So I'd like to be
your equal partner.
You realize both the offers
are the same valuation.
In the case of Robert,
he's paying you
twice as much for 100%.
Lori wants to be
a 50‐50 partner.
But, Niki,
we're not kicking you out.
‐Right, that would ‐‐
‐We want you to stay,
and we'd hire you
as a designer.
I'm giving you the opportunity
to do the things you like.
‐Okay.
Can I ask a question?
‐Of course.
‐You're allowed to talk, Niki.
W‐Wh...
I don't have any questions.
I know what I need to do.
♪♪
Lori...
Let's make a deal.
‐Yay!
‐All right.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐Congratulations.
‐Thank you!
‐Thank you.
Thank you, gentlemen.
‐Awesome!
‐Robert, thank you.
‐I'm so glad.
‐Yes! Thank you!
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you.
Greiner:
Well, you're a great designer.
Thank you so much
for all you do.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
‐Bye. Thank you.
‐Well, we'll be talking.
‐Okay.
‐[ Chuckles ]
Oh, my gosh, baby.
Oh, my God!
That was awesome!
That was brutal.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God!
Awesome!
That was so crazy!
Oh, my gosh.
I decided to go with Lori today
because she voiced
my vision for the company.
She saw the market.
She agreed.
And I can't sell my company
to somebody who doesn't agree
with my vision.